a small group of women are turning the
loss of a loved one in in war into
action the Travis Manion foundation
keeps the memories of fallen troops
alive by bringing their stories to
communities across the country it has
empowered more than 60,000 veterans and
families over the last decade Jan
Crawford talked with three of the
Foundation's leaders including Heather
Kelly she is the daughter-in-law of
White House chief of staff John Kelly
and for the first time on TV she opened
up about the loss of her husband Jan is
at the Marine Corps War Memorial in
Arlington Virginia Jan good morning good
morning so every year a team of runners
comes here to honor the memory of Travis
Manion and Brendan Looney they were
roommates at the Naval Academy killed
three years apart in separate wars
marine lieutenant Robert Kelley who's
the son of General John Kelly was killed
in Afghanistan and now after suffering
the worst loss you can possibly imagine
their families are empowering others to
give back from their first days at the
Naval Academy Travis Manion and Brendan
Looney stood together Brennan and Travis
are really brothers from another mother
so it seemed only fitting that in the
end Travis and Brendan would rest
together
they moved Travis from his Cemetery in
Pennsylvania and buried them
side-by-side here at Arlington President
Obama even paid tribute to their
friendship as an example of America's
best warriors for freedom brothers
forever and their families shared loss
Brendan's wife Amy and Travis's sister
Ryan also found a new beginning you get
to this point that it's like what comes
next
Brennan's mantra that he lived by was be
strong be accountable and never complain
and that be strong be accountable and
never never complain yeah you can be
faced with challenges but it's really
about what are you gonna do
Heather Kelly lost her husband first
lieutenant Robert Kelly in Afghanistan
how did you come through that I think
sometimes it still kind of feels like
it's happened to another person it's
hard to believe that this is Robin I
story does he still feel very much with
you absolutely
yeah absolutely I know Rob I didn't want
to be doing anything else so I have that
piece that it's exactly where he was
meant to be that's a sentiment shared by
Roberts father retired General John
Kelly now serving as White House chief
of staff he knew what he was getting
into
by joining the more that 1% when he died
he was surrounded by the best men on
this earth his friends was that a
surprise when he started talking about
it during the briefing yeah but I trust
my father-in-law a hundred percent and I
know he holds Roberts memory close what
was that like when all of that kind of
became news sometimes the way it's
focused is hard but just in general if
you know people are saying Robert's name
and remembering what he did I'm I'm
happy that his memory lives on in that
way Ryan Heather and Amy know there are
many other families who face the same
loss what would you say to them now I
would say to them you're suffering
probably arguably the most horrible
thing that will ever happen to you
but there is a light ahead for these
women that light was the Travis Manion
foundation named for Ryan's brother and
inspired by one simple phrase we all
asked ourselves if not me then who those
were the five words that my brother
spoke before he left her second
appointment the foundation uses those
words to bring together veterans and
their families with hundreds of
thousands of civilians across the
country those volunteers go on to serve
in different ways cleaning up
communities here at home building houses
in underdeveloped countries or simply
sharing the importance of character with
millions of school-aged children growing
up without a positive role model it's
not only beneficial to the communities
that are receiving that impact through
the work that we do but it's also
beneficial to that gold star family
member or that veteran that's getting
out of the military and wants to feel
that sense of camaraderie and service
and purpose and meaning again the
foundation is also shown these women
sides of themselves they never imagined
I think all of us are just striving to
live lives worthy
Travis and Brendon and Robert sacrifice
all of us in very different ways have
been pushed outside of our comfort zone
what would Brendan say he would be very
proud of some of the accomplishments
that I've had and things that I've
overcome he would be floored that I ran
26.2 miles or climbed it it's not a
bunch of peach I just I I was at a point
where if someone was like yeah this will
this should be great for you to do I
feel like whatever what do I have to
lose you know would Rob be surprised yes
I you know pretty introverted and I know
stuck to our clothes Cooper friends do
you ever think that like I wish he could
ya see me I wish I could tell him I mean
do you does it
does that ever become a conscious
thought I hope they do I do feel like in
some ways you know they did that they
know you know the Mannion foundation is
kicking off a ten day service project
with volunteer opportunities across the
country each project is inspired by the
legacy of a fallen service member Nora
Oh Jan thank you so much for bringing us
that interview and that story and
highlighting their work and I love that
they're finding meaning and continuing
service you know service to others
really beautifully done and promoting
that phrase if not me then who which is
still a very small percentage of
Americans who take that oath Thank You
Jan again